I can't really be a lawyer and a criminal can i
I want to win but do i want to win like this
i'm of two minds here so it's a coin flip
johnny vitti was murdered tonight falcone
crime family has to be taken down
there's only room for one
homicidal maniac in this town
Why are you running. you could use a little fun.
Ithought you didn't hurt people you thought wrong
you still haven't figured out who killed
johnny vitti a killer who only works on holidays
there's lots of crazy out there
once i take him out things are going
gonna be different we can start a family
the city has fallen alfred then we must endeavor
to lift it up again
who is holiday and who's next
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
batman long halloween trailer video jensen
ackles batman bet you did not see that coming
jensen ackle's finally playing a version of the
batman so a whole bunch of easter eggs here long
halloween obviously one of the best batman stories
from the last 25-30 years almost but if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos there's so much batman stuff
happening in the next couple of years between this
batman movie there's two parts to it this is just
part one part two will be released later this year
we have ben affleck's batman and the justice
league snyder cut just a little while ago and
then we have the upcoming matt reeves batman movie
with robert pattinson's version of the character
even though that's taking place in an alternate
universe from the justice league ben affleck
batman most of you probably remember though jensen
ackles actually played red hood during the batman
under the red hood movie in the early 2000s listen
to me you drug peddling scumbags you eight of the
most prosperous street dealers in gotham i'm
offering you morons a deal i believe that was
around the time he was doing smallville so that
was actually his early start in the dc universe
they actually just released another jason todd
movie under the red hood it was sort of a choose
your own adventure movie and jen's and apples
did not come back to play red hood so i think
this is why because they already had him doing the
voice for batman during the long halloween movie
if you don't remember a couple years ago too
stephen amell and jensen were both campaigning
to get him as the version of batman inside
the arrowverse obviously that didn't pan out
i think mostly because there were so many versions
of live-action batman that they were getting ready
for it was still ben affleck batman and the
justice league snyder cut stuff there was the
big transition behind the scenes to matt reeves
robert pattinson batman movies and then they were
apparently still trying to get michael keaton
batman to come back so even without that titan's
version of batman you have three live-action
versions of batman flying around so if you
wonder why you haven't seen batman in a really big
way inside the aeroverse dc tv shows that's why
either way it's a really good time to be a batman
fan and the reason why they're doing this movie is
two parts instead of just doing it as a one
two hour movie or an hour and a half like the
typical animated movie length is because the
long halloween is a really big story and they
want to do the entire story without having to
speedrun everything that being said though you
can actually tell just from part one of this story
that they've already cut out some of the batman
villains although a lot of the key ones are there
so i'll explain some of the minor changes it seems
like they've made and if you guys didn't know matt
reeves was actually inspired by portions of the
long halloween for his new robert pattinson batman
movie although obviously that's meant to be an
original story with some similar elements to the
long halloween so they're not doing the exact long
halloween story line the way the animated movie is
trying to adapt the comic book but the whole thing
with a long halloween story is it's basically a
murder mystery that takes place during a bunch
of different holidays that's why they call the
main villain the holiday killer it's a neo-noir
big whodunit story with batman basically going
around being the world's greatest detective very
big detective story trying to learn the identity
just going around to all the different members of
his rogues gallery of villains thinking that each
one might be responsible the person you see batman
and gordon talking to in that prison cell in the
trailer that's calendar man he's being played
by david dasmartian who's also in the suicide
squad movie as polkadot man just really big fan
of playing obscure characters calendar man is in
prison because he's known for committing holiday
themed crimes on holidays and because in the long
halloween story all these different murders are
happening on different holidays they go to him
for advice but the other big thing about the
long halloween is that it's meant to take place
relatively early in his career so for instance
catwoman big character during this being played
by naya rivera i guess she did the voiceover role
for this before she passed away so may she rest
in peace but at this point in batman's career
he hasn't learned catwoman's secret identity
and he's dating selena kyle as bruce wayne
selena kyle also doesn't know that bruce wayne is
batman yet so that kind of gives you an idea for
where this takes place in his timeline but even
though you have pretty much every major character
like the joker from his rogues gallery most
of the story revolves around the mob in gotham
city between the maroneys and the falcone crime
families it's also meant to be a bit of an origin
story for the two-faced harvey dent character
like him slowly becoming the two-faced character
that's why you see in the trailer then making
all those references to him flipping the coin
trying to make the choice so the story begins in
a very godfather type of way at a mob wedding it's
carmine falcone throwing a wedding for his
family but bruce wayne is there with selena
kyle as his date and his friend harvey dent while
he's there carmine falcone is trying to pressure
bruce wayne to launder his money his billions of
dollars through the banks that falcone's control
because harvey dent is the district attorney who's
going after the mob the falcones have him beaten
up bruce wayne finds him then after the party
as batman he develops a plan to take down the
falconies take control the banks away from him
with harvey dent and gordon harvey then is going
to use the head of the bank to testify against
falcone and put him behind bars but the falcones
have the president of the bank killed so that he
can't testify against them then in retaliation
a mystery killer the holiday killer winds up
killing the falcone responsible for taking out
the president of the bank the scene where you
see harvey dent in batman sitting in front of
that giant pile of money and he's talking about
being a district attorney maybe being a criminal
flipping the coin they find a warehouse where
falcone was forced to stash 20 million dollars
and obviously this is taking place 25 years ago so
you have to imagine it probably like 100 million
dollars if the story was written today and as part
of their plan batman harvey dent gordon's plan to
take down the mob they burn the money christopher
nolan actually used some of those story elements
from the long halloween during the dark knight
movie where you have joker burning pretty much
half of the mob's money but then as the year goes
on throughout the major holidays like thanksgiving
valentine's day christmas all these big holidays
you start to see the holiday killer taking out all
these different key members of the different crime
families is part of batman's investigation as he's
going around at each of the crime scenes holiday
just winds up leaving holiday-themed calling cards
eventually holliday's actions lead to an all-out
war between the maroneys and the falcones
sal moroney winds up making a deal with batman
gordon in dent to testify against falcone and put
him away for good and it's at that courtroom trial
where harvey then gets the acid thrown in his face
so he goes to the hospital but before they can
take him to surgery he winds up escaping into
the sewer stabbing his surgeon later in the story
he resurfaces as full-blown two-faced to go after
falcone winds up releasing a whole bunch of
prisoners from arkham causes all this mayhem
so like i said seems very similar to some of
the plot elements from the dark knight movie
using all this dark knight footage like which
movie you talking about long halloween of the
dark knight well obviously you can see how much
christopher nolan borrowed from the long halloween
joker winds up causing all kinds of mayhem
trying to take out the holiday killer himself
because he's jealous he doesn't want the attention
taken away from him he's supposed to be the
biggest criminal in the city but even while
you have two-face going after falcone himself
successfully getting revenge nobody the entire
time ever figures out who the holiday killer
is it still winds up being this huge mystery right
up until the end of the story i don't want to give
away huge spoilers but the story has been out for
like the last 25 years so most you probably know
what's going on with the holiday killer the big
twist behind it but it is meant to be a big twist
reveal at the end of the story where they don't
literally tell you who the killer is but they give
you all the clues like it's right there on the
page like oh it was this person the whole time
the person you least suspect but what's going to
happen is they're releasing part one of the movie
june 22nd and then part two i believe is supposed
to be released sometime this fall i think
originally what they plan to do because so much
of matt reeve's batman movie has long halloween
energy in it even though it's not directly
adapting the story they wanted to release part two
of the jensen ackles long halloween movie around
the same time they were going to drop the batman
movie in theaters which was originally going to be
in october this year but then they pushed that to
march next year but because the long halloween
was an animation movie they don't have the same
issues filming during the virus so they didn't
have to bump that so i believe both parts will
come out this year and if you didn't see matt
reeves actually just posted on his social media
accounts a little while ago he wrapped filming
on the batman movie so that means we'll probably
get a full batman trailer sometime later this year
maybe around the time they released the dune movie
which is going to be in october but if you haven't
read the long halloween story i would recommend
you check it out at some point because it is one
of the best batman stories from the last 25 years
what's going to happen next though is my marvel
falcon and winter soldier episode 4 video we'll
post friday just like normal and there's a whole
bunch of stuff going on this weekend i'll try to
post all those videos as quickly as possible just
leave all your requests in the comments below we
also have the mortal kombat movie coming up in a
couple weeks too so i'll be doing some videos for
that pretty soon as well while you wait for
everything click here for my justice league
snyder cut ending and then credit scene video and
learn about what's going on with the sequels and
click here for my marvel falcon and winter soldier
episode 4 video i'll update the link when i post
that new video too thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!